le gars a quand même traversé tous les
pays avec une caméra en demandant aux
gens s'ils pouvaient dormir chez eux je
peux venir avec vous chez vous c'est
incroyable et en général ça s'est bien
passé salut aujourd'hui on va recevoir
Antoine de maximie qui a accepté de nous
raconter un petit peu des choses qu'
raconte pas habituellement sur ce qu'il
a vécu dans son émission gérer dormir
chez vous les autres interviews à la
table existent en playlist et c'est dans
la description bonne vidéo 20 ans sans
émission s passant émission 100 pays
alors c'est 100 à peu près 120 pays 60
moins de presque 70 pour la série les
émissions il y en a bah il y a 67
épisodes plus tous les trucs Burning Man
j'irais dormir à Hollywood Bollywood tu
résumes ça comme tu veux là tu as les
chiffres à peu près ben non on peut le
résumer en une question on dort mieux
chez soi ou dort mieux chez moi mais il
y a la différence c'est pas fondamentale
tu dors sous un abri de branchage en
Éthiopie avec se frères et puis que tont
laissé peut-être par gentillesse en plus
tu sais pas un caillou arrondi au niveau
de la tête qui peut faire un quelque
sorte un oreiller B tu dors moins bien
que chez quelqu'un qui a une grande
maison j'en sais rien Mo ah ou aller
tiens oui puis en plus comme tu dis ce
gros caillou peut pas t'en plaindre
parce que si ça se trouve c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est sacrifié pour pas le
l'avoir ce soir c'est possible toi tu as
on te connait avec j'ais dormir j'allais
dormir chez vous on sait un peu moins
que tu as été reporteur de guerre
reporte animalier pourquoi tu as arrêté
ça pour monter ce projet là et déjà
peut-être ma question est fausse
peut-être que tu as pas arrêté ça pour
lancer ce projet peut-être ça a été une
continuité si j'ai arrêté parce que
j'avais envie de faire autre chose en
fait moi j'ai compris très jeune qu'on a
qu'une vie alors peut-être que on en a
deux mais on en parlera à ce moment-là
pour l'instant on est sur une base qui
ressemble à une seule vie et donc je
l'exploite et j'en profite autant que je
peux et donc depuis le début surtout et
donc quand je je fais des tournages qui
sont vraiment exceptionnels entre les
films d'expédition scientifique et que
je dis je vais faire girirai dormir chez
vous ou je vais pas être payé au début
parce que personne veut d'émissions et
ben c'est parce que parce que je pense
que j'en ai fait suffisamment et que
bien sûr la facilité serait de continuer
et moi j'ai envie de découvrir d'autres
choses et de et de m'amuser de toute
façon tant que je m'amuse ça va oui puis
en fait tu crées l'opportunité de vivre
ce que tu as envie de vivre toi et après
de le documenter c'est un peu dans cet
ordre là en fait oui oui benah toute
façon c'est ça je je pars pas en voyage
si je vais pas faire un film ouais non
là je reviens de vacances je suis resté
en France je suis allé voir mes copains
à droite à gauche dans des endroits pas
spécialement touristiques par que je
m'en fous quand à l'époque tu te dis je
vais aller faire ça comme tu dis il y a
pas forcément d'argent parce que
personne fait forcément de l'émission tu
créais toi-même ton système pour filmer
c'est ta première réflexion ça c'est ton
premier enjeu ou pas de se dire est-ce
que je suis capable de produire de
l'Image et du Son oui ça fait partie en
fait la l'idée de j'iraai dormir chez
vous ça repose sur plein de trucs ça
repose sur effectivement ce défi
technique mais moi j'avais été ingénieur
du son caméraman réalisateur
présentateur donc je me disais je peux
faire tout seul mais je savais pas si
j'allais y arriver et puis desffet
techniqu c'est-à-dire de mettre au point
de faire mettre au point parce que
techniquement c'est pas moi qui l'ai
fait mais une caméra au bout de la tige
la deuxième là une troisième à la main
les micros au bon endroit pour que le
son soit correct et cetera ou puis on
parle d'une époque où il y a pas les
GoPro avec les batteries c'est des
caméras qui alors au début il y avait
des petites caméras mais qui étaient pas
de bonne qualité après on a fait faire
des caméras ok carrément prendre un
camescope qui a un truc camescope de
point et le défaire en petit
morceaupouer pour le faire le plus petit
possible OK MRE un autre objectif dans
un petit boîtier tout le reste au bout
d'un câble l'enregistreur dans le sac à
dos alors que au départ c'est un
appareil monobloc Sony ils ont dit ça
marchera pas ça a marché ça bien marché
mais ce que ce que j'ai envie de savoir
c'est ce qui se passe dans ta tête dans
ces momentsl est-ce que tu avances très
confiant vers je faire ce truc qui s'est
jamais fait techniquement faut qu'on
relève le défi du pognon bon on en a pas
est-ce que tu doute est-ce que tu as
peur ou est-ce que vraiment tu dis non
non mais on va trouver un chemin et puis
on y va en fait je veux pas avirre
regret donc j'essaye plein de trucs et
j'accepte qu'un projet ne marche pas ok
à partir du moment où j'ai tout fait ce
que je pouvais c'est ça pour y arriver
parce que le problème souvent c'est on
se dit je vais pas y arriver ou c'est
pas sûr que ça marche et on abandonne on
essaye pas on n pas été exploré voilà et
ça je pense que c'est le pire et le
meilleur exemple que j'ai c'est quand
j'ai mis pour la première fois le
matériel chez moi ça tenaitc du scotch
c'était mal foutu et tout mais c'était
juste pour faire un test et je me
regarde dans la glace mais nul je range
tout je replie et je c'est prévu de le
rendre et 1 heure après je me dis faut
que j'aille jusqu'au bout parce que
sinon je risque d'avoir des regrets soit
parce que les années sont passées puis
je me dis que si j'avais fait ça que
j'aurais peut-être dû voir pire un autre
mec l'a fait ouais et ça c'est tu peux
pas vivre après avoir il te prouve que
tu avais tort là voilà donc le j'ai tout
remis j'y suis allé pour vérifier que
c'était une mauvaise idée et quand j'ai
regardé les images 2 heur après je me
suis dit ah bah non c'est pas mal du
tout et oui parce que les gens étaient
complètement naturels cétait pas du tout
dérangé par le matériel parce que tu as
l'air d'un pour moi tu étais
l'équivalent de l'homme orchestre mais
en version audiovisuelle i oui c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit remémi BRIC de la vidéo
ouais c'est ça c'est ça absolument et
effectivement tu dis tiens est-ce que ça
peut les arrêter en fait réellement tu
les filmes pas vraiment je demande ouais
quand tu as quelqu'un qui qui te filme
il est caché un peu
c'est comme si tu le pointais du doigt
en fait tu es comme ça tu lui parles
mais tu es comme ça même si tu tiens la
caméra comme ça tu es quand même en
train de filmer quand tu as les mains
libres le regard libre même s'il y a ce
harnis qui est pas grand je veux dire la
tige elle fait comme le doigt elle est
longue comme ça le reste c'est petit
c'est c'est pas gênant c'est pas
intrusif ben à ce moment-là moi j'ai le
regard qui est libre les mains qui sont
libres et donc je discute comme avec toi
avec le micro qui est là tu vois on a le
micro qui est là mais on se regarde je
trouve que que même le micro est plus
gênant que mes caméras je pense aussi
ouais ouais parce que je vois mal le
battre ton visage c'est ça et c'est
intéressant et et l'idée en est même du
j'irai dormir chez vous qui est quand
même encore autre chose que je vais dans
un pays à la rencontre des gens ça te
vient toi tout seul tu as un flash tuas
oui c'est vraiment cette idée à part
quelques détails que je peux dire tout
de suite c'est la la mise en image les
les scratch les les les volets qui qui
tout ce qui est du graphisme en fait euh
ça c'est pas de moi la chemise rouge
tout le temps c'est pas de moi moi je
comptais je m'en foutais quoi voilà et
mais en revanche tout le reste c'est moi
le titre l'idée faire comme
si c'est c'est tout et pourquoi comment
c'est venu je suis allé au marché une
première fois marché de la Goutte d'Or
après je suis allé à Belleville deuxème
essai et puis bah je regarde puis je
sais pas ce que je vais faire je suis en
train de me balader l'idée est de
rencontrer des gens mais tout à coup je
dis à la caméra mais tu sais comme ça
sans avoir prévu sans avoir réfléchi
c'est spontané je dis ah bah tiens je
vais faire un truc rigolo on va aller
dîner chez quelqu'un déjeuner chez
quelqu'un OK et je commence comme ça et
je trouve une dame qui accepte que je
vienne et donc je vais chez elle avec
juste une caméra et là elle me raconte
que il y a eu un jeune qui s'est fait
tuer dans la rue en bas de chez elle sa
fille qui a 11 ou 12 ans qui est à côté
euh moi je dis il y a souvent des des
trucs comme ça elle me dit oui il y en a
et sa fille dit oh bah non il y en a pas
tant que ça il y a juste le mec qui
s'est fait tuer dans l'immeuble tu te
rends compte que la personne la personne
qui t'a invité est personne qui sort de
l'ordinaire ouis tu vois qui a une
histoire ouais tout le monde a une
histoire au final oui mais ces gens qui
sont plus ouverts que d'autres souvent
ils ont une histoire qui peut être plus
forte et surtout ils sauront mieux la
raconter est-ce que tu penses que du
coup il t'ouvre la porte par ces fures
là en fait entre guillemets pour eux
c'est plus facile de se projeter bah oui
il a qu'à venir manger à la mais maison
parce que ils ont déjà vécu pas mal de
choses et eu et eu un regard sur la vie
différent de celui qui a qui a rien
traversé et qui du coup va juste se
mettre mais pourquoi il veut venir
manger chez moi qu'est-ce qu'il me veut
est-ce qu'il est dangereux c'est vrai
c'est vrai et c'est dû aussi au au fait
que euh les les gens et d'ailleurs
souvent les plus pauvres aussi c'est les
gens qui sont les plus confrontés d'une
part à
l'entraide d'autre part euh ils ont pas
peur qu'on leur vole ce qu'ils ont ont
pas grand chose oui ont
et en fait ils sont plus libres que les
gens plus riches qui se protègent plus
et et c'est vrai que c'est des gens qui
vont parler plus facilement toute façon
mon matériel fait déjà un premier tri
quand j'arrive ça fait un premier tri
c'està dire que les les timorés les
introvertis quand il me voi arriver
je les vois même pas ils disparaissent
oui c'est vrai ça ça t'aise
déjà alors toi tu fais tes essais après
tu vas partir dans d'autre pays je me
posais la question je me dit tiens
comment Antoine il choisit ses ses ses
destinations comment il se dit tiens je
vais aller là plutôt que là j'ai fait le
premier épisode au Mali parce que le
Mali était un pays francophone exotique
j'étais déjà allé je savais que les gens
étaient sympa joyeux et cetera c'était
pas un pays particulièrement tendu et
donc je me suis dit je vais essayer là
parce que si jamais je ramène pas
grandchose d'intéressant il va rester
l'exotisme et le côté sympathique
donc j'aurais quand même quelque chose
et le deuxième épisode je me suis dit il
faut que je montre le plus vite possible
la richesse et la variété des choses
donc le deuxième épisode c'est le Québec
en hiver parce que tu passes du d'un
pays chaud à un pays froid d'un pays
pauvre à un pays riche d'un pays
exotique un pays pas du tout exotique
tout en gardant un pays francophone
ouais et le troisième pays c'était le
vanouatou dans le Pacifique qui était
avant les Nouvelles Hébrides où on parle
français mais pas que anglais aussi et
puis les dialectes locaux mais c'était
un un truc qui était tellement différent
des deux premiers parce qu'en fait moi
j'ai dit je veux faire cette émission là
et on m'a dit oui d'accord bon ok c'est
rigolo mais une fois que tu auras fait
un T la même chose ça va être tout le
temps pareil et ben non pas du tout
parce que les gens sont différents les
mentalités sont différentes les pays
sont très variés et puis il y a un
dernier truc qui joue c'est que moi ça
m'emmerde de faire la même chose donc
j'ai vite les mêmes configurations même
si je peux ok pour que l'émission j'en
suis à 67 67 épisodes qui sont tu as pas
l'impression de voir la même chose mais
mais moi c'est ça qui me fascine chez
toi et c'est pour ça que je voulais
qu'on discute je veux comprendre
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête pour
aimer à ce point passe-moi le terme être
emmerdé c'estd que je trouve que dans la
plupart des projets les gens essayent de
limiter leur taux d'emmerdement le
plusôt et toi j'ai l'impression que il y
a juste l'idée est bonne puis il faut
que ça change et puis bon ben il va
falloir se trembbaler avec du matériel
va falloir construire des choses qui
n'existent pas falloir aller dans des
endroits différents et puis j'ai pas
envie de refaire la même chose donc bah
je vais tenter des choses à chaque fois
nouvelles j'arrête pas c'est génial oui
j'arrête pas je je mais tu sais je me
rappelle je disais ça tu aux États-Unis
en Louisiane à un moment quand j'ai fait
le longmétrage là j'irais dormir à
Hollywood je dis
ouis en fait c'est ça que je fais je me
fous dans la merde et je vois comment je
m'en sors c'est ça oui mais c'est ça qui
est marrant il faut pas non plus faire
des trucs o tu as toutes les Chan de ne
pas t'en sortir mais c'est intéressant
de risquer ce que j'ai encore fait il y
a pas longtemps Kazakhstan où je je
prends sur la carte sur la photo
satellite un village qui n'a aucun
intérêt particulier et j'essaie d'y
aller sans parler le casac là-bas il
parle pas anglais Quand tu es dans les
campagnes et cetera et ben c'est drôle
c'est drôle c'est compliqué mais c'est
drôle tu flirtes un peu avec la peur
c'està-dire il y a des moments où ça te
stresse d'angoisse l'inconnuou pas que
je va avoir peur ouais c'est ça non je
dis que effectivement ça peut être
éventuellement compliqué mais je sais
pas encore que je vais avoir peur le
truc c'est d'y aller un un peu quoi à à
quel moment socialement tu penses que tu
es moins sensible au danger que les
autres moi dans dans tout ce que j'ai vu
de toi mais je me dis tiens c'est
marrant là j'aurais je me serais mis en
retrait plusutôt là je j'aurais été un
peu entouré j'aurais stressé plutôt et
et en plus je rajoute la composante je
me dis il a du matériel sur
lui qui est peut-être un symbole de
richesse dans le point de vue des autres
tu vois je trouve que tu as une
sensibilité comme ça à au danger qui qui
est qui est moins exacerbé que la nôtre
est-ce que ça c'est venu progressivement
ou est-ce
que reportage de guerre bien sûr moi
j'ai commencé à faire du reportage de
guerre à Beyrouth c'était une guerre
civile et les gens avaient pas compris
du tout ça nous on était au milieu je
veux dire le envoyait passer des chars
il se tiraent dessus et nous on était au
milieu parfois ça arrivait des mecs qui
se sont fait tuer on en a vu des morts
on en a vu des des balles qui sont
passées pas très loin on en a eu et tout
ça fait que je me me suis retrouvé dans
des situations où la nature humaine
était complètement exacerbée aussi bien
les journalistes entre eux que le mec
qui vient de perdre quelqu'un de proche
et tu t'aperçois que même le mec qui
vient de perdre quelqu'un peut avoir un
moment où il craque et il rigole ouais
tu vois on a des trucs comme ça et c'est
pas des choses que je peux expliquer que
je peux analyser et décomposer c'est des
trucs que tu pourras jamais apprendre
dans une école oui tu l'as expérimenté
et c'est du ressenti mais c'est pas une
sence
le danger c'est que c'est pas une siance
exacte et je sais aussi que les les par
exemple les les on va dire les les gens
un peu un peu voyou les durs et cetera
apprécient aussi le courage ouais ils te
respecteront pour ça moi j'ai déjà eu
des gens mais attends tu viens ici tu es
tout seul mais qui te protège oua tell
il a du respect pour toi oui c'est vrai
et puis il y a aussi un autre truc c'est
que je suis un poisson bizarre moi on
sait pas qui je suis ce que je fais on n
jamais vu alors maintenant ça commence à
changer de nouveau puisque maintenant il
y a les blogueurs mais moi je suis
arrivé bienavant les blogueurs ah bien
sûr les les bandits on va dire ou les
les mecs qui pourraient éventuellement
te te piquer ton matos et tout ils
savent pas qui tu es comme ils sont pas
cons ils regardent d'abord tu un poisson
curieux est-ce que tes caméras sont pas
reliés en direct pour une expérience
avec le commissariat d' côté ouais on
sait pas ils savent pas ouais donc bah
ils attaquent pas pas à la légère ouais
donc tu provoques une petite confusion
en même temps de bon on l'observe lui
autant qu'il n observe ouais c'est
intéressant avant d'aller dans dans un
pays tu tu prépares un peu c'estàd des
notions de langue de culture de choses
comme ça d'intégration nonès très peu si
tu
prépares tu vas te baser sur le travail
de ceux qui sont passés avant ça va être
soit des reportages soit des lectures
donc c'est fait par un mec qui est passé
avant le mec qui est passé avant il a
préparé et il s'est basé également sur
le mec qui a travaillé avantant donc ce
qui se passe le gros problème de ce Tru
là c'est que en plus quand tu as quand
tu as préparé essaie d'obtenir ce que tu
as préparé ce que tu as écrit ce que tu
t'attends à trouver oui tu veux pas te
décevoir toi-même tu avais préparé ça tu
penses que ça va être comme ça résultat
la le pays évolue beaucoup plus vite que
ce qu'on en connaît h alors que si tu
arrives sans avoir rien préparé tu
découvres le pays tel qu'il est du coup
à chaque fois tu découvres des pays tu
découvres des familles est-ce que des
fois ça a transpererscé un peu des des
barrières au point d'avoir un vrai
attachement spontané à un lieu à une
famille à des gens un peu mais moi j'ai
envie trop de de bouger c'est pas mon
truc de m'attacher tu as gardé des
contacts ou pas avec les gens qui t'ont
ACC très peu en fait parce que c'est
comme les amours de vacances c'estàdire
tu passes un moment qui peut être fort
il est bref ouais et après chacun repart
dans sa vie et moi même à la limite j'ai
plus de souvenirs et de de sentiments
même pour les gens que j'ai filmé ouais
que eux parce que moi j'ai traversé leur
vie i oui c'est vrai je suis arrivé
genre à 17h on a j'ai débarqué c'était
la fête c'était quelque chose de nouveau
ça changeait et cetera j'ai on a dîner
j'ai dormi sur place le lendemain j'ai
disparu alors que moi j'ai fait vécu la
même chose si ce n'est que j'ai fait le
montage que je revois l'épisode
régulièrement et cetera donc ces gens-l
j'ai souvenir assez précis oui parce que
toi tu es une anecdote de vie pour eux
ouais tu te souviens la fois où il y a
le mec qui est venu dormir à la maison
quand ils s'en souviennent peut-être
ouis c'est je pense quand même qu'ils
s'en souviennent du coup si tu prépares
pas au niveau culturel au niveau des
langues et cetera les malentendu
culturel est-ce que c'est le point de
départ d'une histoire ça peut mais c'est
drôle parce que d'abord il y a un truc
qu'il faut voir c'est que ça les choses
ont complètement changé il y a
50 ans on te disait il faut pas refuser
tu vas les vexer par exemple pour un
plat en tout cas c'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui j'ai encore fait
l'expérience récemment au Vietnam sort
un truc imbouffable la crevette pourrie
ils font pourrir des crevettes pendant 6
mois pour faire une sauce bon c'est pas
tout à fait ma culture et ben je leur ai
dit je leur ai dit écoute moi je ve dire
franchement je trouve que ça sent la
merde et la fille elle éclate de rire
elle éclate de rire on dit ce qu'on veut
c'est pas à toi qui regarde l'épisode
qui va me dire ce que je dois dire à la
nana qui rigole puisque elle ça la fait
rire on peut le dire et puis et puis en
plus la sincérité ça crée ça ce choc de
rire de oh là là il veut pas manger mes
CR invers les choses un Japonais tu le
sors à Marwal ouais est-ce qu'il va te
vexer s'il le mange pas ouais non mais
c'est ça va te faire rigoler toi tu es
sors le Marwal parce que justement tu
veux voir sa tête c'est ça oua c'est
pareil et les gens en général la
majorité des gens préfèire rigoler que
de rallerin dans dans certains épisodes
quand même tu as eu des galères descenus
un des souven marquant où ça été
vraiment une grosse galère pour toi une
grosse galère au point de te dire mais
dans quoi je me suis embarqué là ce
ccias tu as différents trucs tu vois je
veux dire ça peut être très rapide tu
aller tu sens que les mecs devant c'est
vraiment tu risques d'avoir des
problèmes c'est la même question dans
quoi je me suis embarqué quand je me
retrouve en Bolivie ça s en 2006 avec
une fausse policière qui veut me faire
monter dans un taxi et qui dit qu'elle
est policière elle est pas du tout et
cetera parce que c'est c'est c'est quoi
l'histoire elle tu tu te fais arrêter
dans la rue en jeine jein qui me dit
qu'elle est policière en civil tu as pas
le droit de filmer donne-moi ton
autorisation angle oui et je dis bah
j'ai pas d'autorisation vous êtes de la
police oui faites voir votre carte de
police je te la montrerai quand tu auras
montré ton autorisation ce qui veut dire
clairement je ne suis pas de la police
et et elle veut que je monte dans un
taxi et comme j'aurais je m'énerve je
résiste parle de l'ambassade les gens ça
troupe les flics arrivent les vrai souci
et on se retrouve tous au commissariat
et ben après quand moi je suis parti en
Amazonie et je suis remonté à la pase et
ben il y avait des gens qui me
cherchaient ah ouais il me cherchait et
quand tu as des gens qui te cherchent et
que toi dans ton but c'est de rencontrer
des gens que tu connais pas ouais tu
peux pas rester sur place très
honnêtement je suis parti de là où
j'étais dans la une voiture de
l'ambassade de France cachée ok j'ai
dormi dans la résidence de l'ambassadeur
et le lendemain matin je prenais un
avion ouais F ça quoi ah oui là là moi
je quand ça devient dangereux et que je
considère c'est dangereux je mets pas 10
minutes à agir non mais je trouve c'est
important qu'on t'entende aussi le dire
je trouve qu'on est assez admiratif de
ce que tu fais pour la plupart parce que
nous-même on ça nous renvoie nous-même
est-ce que j'oserais est-ce que je sais
rencontrer les gens au sens littéral du
terme il se passe quoi d'un ta la
première fois que que tu dis à quelqu'un
et je peux dormir chez vous et que la
personne dit bah ouais tu dis c'est
gagné ou c'est quoi et ben je me dis
ouais je me dis NON je me dis exactement
ouais c'est gagné et cetera et puis
après puisque j'apprends en permanence
ça c'est un truc que j'ai bien compris
depuis longtemps c'est que il faut pas
aller chez n'importe qui non pas parce
qu'il risque de m'arriver quelque chose
ça la probabilité est faible si le mec
il vient te proposer d'aller chez lui là
tu peux te poser les questions c'est toi
qui a demandé il y a Pasu de chance que
tu tombe sur le psychopathe de la de la
ville en revanche quand tu crois que
quand le mec dit oui et si tu fonces bah
moi avant de demander maintenant
j'essaie de voir si le mec est
intéressant ouais parce qu'il m'est
arrivé que le mec il dise oui et puis Mo
je dis ouais ouais Mo se couche pas un
mot et tu te fais chier parce que le mec
a rien à dire non mais parce que on a
dit qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
fasse bah je sais pas je pensais qu'on
allait boire un ver ENF tu is non parce
que nous on oublie parce qu'on voit
forcément le meilleur de ce que tu as pu
vivre dans les images je bah j'ai montré
justement il y a pas longtemps là dans
l'épisode Serbie j'ai montré ce que
c'était qu'une soirée loose je marche je
rencontre presque personne il se passe
rien et puis je vais me coucher c'est
génial et ben voilà ou mais ça fait
partie aussi du pro oui bien sûr et moi
j'ai toujours aimé enfin c'est vraiment
et je l'ai vu ça finit avec les années
ta manière de mander elle est tellement
maline parce que il y a des fois où je
vois quand quand et tu m'arrêtes si je
me trompe hein j'essaie de rentrer dans
ta tête quand je regarde je dis ah là il
est malin parce que tu es un mentaliste
he pour moi tuas ta manière de juger les
gens et de les emmener et et des fois
quand je te vois avoir quelqu'un où tu
dis mentalement ça va être un peu dur je
vois que tu l'emmènes à imaginer un jeu
ah ouais et si je si je vous disais que
je dormais chez vous vous pour voir hein
ah ouais hein vous diriez oui vous
diriez non ah ouais ouais on a qu'à le
faire et je vois c'est hop là étape par
étape c'est tout à fait vrai et je
m'adapte vachement à la personne que
j'ai en face de moi beaucoup beaucoup et
je peux même passer caméléon ouais
c'est-à-dire j'arrive je sens que le mec
je peux lui rentrer dans le chou et que
ça va être drôle et donc je rentre dans
le chou il le prend hyper mal et la
phrase d'après en face de lui il a un
mec qui a rien à voir qui est gentil qui
est amical qui est parce que c'est une
espèce de de jout c'est un jeu ouais et
et c'est un jeu aussi pour moi donc
c'est d'arriver à à trouver le truc et à
m'en faire un ami tu vois et je dirais
que j'ai quand même été beaucoup plus
surpris par le côté positif des gens que
par l'inverse c'est-à-dire que il
m'arrive beaucoup plus souvent de
trouver un mec qui a l'air renfrogier
pas très sympa et cetera et puis dès que
tu lui parles son visage s'illumine et
cetera alors que l'inverse est beaucoup
plus rare est-ce que tu as vécu des
moments de vie où tu t'es dit mince
j'ai pas filmé ça ah ça ça do
être la frustration elle doit être
terrible bah je pense que on vient d'en
parler je pense que le truc le pire que
j'ai raté de toute ma vie c'est
justement en Bolivie ouais parce qu'en
Bolivie la nana elle arrive devant moi
et je filmais avec ma caméra de point et
les paluches étaient coupé ok j'ai pas
pensé à la relancer toute la séquence où
elle me dit je suis une policière machin
et cetera ça n'a pas tourné OK et je
m'en suis sorti parce
que tu vas voir que le côté profession
elle passe avant certaines choses
peut-être la sécurité d'une certaine
manière c'est que je m'aperçois que j'ai
pas filmé et la nana elle est déjà en
train de repartir je la rattrape ah
ouais tu as relancé tu r je la rattrape
pour continuer la discussion je la
relance alors je prends moins de risque
il y a déjà l'roupement et c'est à ce
moment-l qu'arrive les policiers ok mais
sinon elle serait partie ouais et donc
elle aurait même pas été en c'est ça
ououi c'est ça ce al il a passé de jours
mais écoute si ça a pu la calmer un peu
parce que je sais pas ce qui serait
passé hein ouais il m'aurait tout pris
ça c'est sûr est-ce qu'il m'aurait tué
ou pas tué ou c'est ça la destination du
taxi elle était pas CLA est-ce que
est-ce que tu as déjà dû censurer ton
émission pour pouvoir la diffuser c'est
on t'a dit là c'est trop chaud ou là
c'est trop alors il y a eu des petits
trucs par exemple la fois où en Corée du
Nord je termine dans un état second on
sait pas si c'est parce que j'ai trop bu
ou parce que j'ai mangé une herbe
bizarre c'est passé à la télé je veux
dire quand tu vois que c'est le
présentateur de l'mion était bizarre
Ctait les liquid écoute avec recul je
crois que c'était les liquides que
j'avais pas mangé depuis la veille mais
je savais pas du tout et j'ai dormi 6h
mais on rit tellement quand on voit
cette séquence que mais un jour ça sera
interdit hein là on parlait beaucoup de
l'émission mais tu as joué ton spectacle
j'irais dormir sur scène oui on s'est
pas emmerdé pour le titre
ouis la communication est je te laisse
nous parler de ce projet j'ai envie de
savoir pourquoi d'où ça vient et cetera
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce spectacle
enfin je sais mais je veux que tu le
redises en fait les gens ne savent pas
ce que j'ai fait avant j'irais dormir
chez vous et ce qui a fait que je j'ai
pu faire girer dormir chez vous j'ai
plongé à 5000 m dans un sous-marin je
suis descendu dans un volcan pour
chercher de la lave je suis allé dans
des gouffres de glace dans la calotte
glacière du groinland descendre 200 m
dans une cathédrale de glace j'ai fait
quatre expéditions avec le rade des Sims
qui pose une plateforme de 600 m² sur
les forêts en Amazonie par exemple et
plein d'autres trucs comme ça et bien
j'ai les images de tout ça donc moi j'ai
raconté où j'avais comment j'avais
appris à avoir l'idée et à faire j'iraai
dormir chez vous mais j'ai montré les
images h et la conférence elle fait 1h
et3 et tu as 50 minutes d'images et qui
sont toutes plus spectaculaires les unes
que les autres c'est dire que à chaque
fois que tu vois un truc bah tu es comme
ça tu vois quand tu fais des plongées
avec deux sous-marins c'est une autre
expédition qui plonge à 1000 m mais
qu'il y en a un qui filme l'autre ben tu
vis cette plongée et ça c'est
extraordinaire et des trucs comme ça
j'en ai fait plein du coup toi tu aimes
bien rencontrer les gens mais après tu
aimes bien reverser ce que tu
asér euh à l'étranger et puis pas
ramener des images merci pour tout ça
ben écoute ravi hein cétait un super
échange c'est frustrant parce qu'on a
envie d' l'écouter parler plus longtemps
d'ailleurs dans quelques semaines il y a
la version longue qui sort en podcast
sur toutes les plateformes de podcast à
très bientôt Ciao